it's the most popular docu-series on
Netflix right now and it's captured the
imagination of the entire country I'm
talking about Tiger King of course and
we're lucky enough today on the show to
have one of the principles from the
docu-series please welcome one of the
Tigers from the GW Zoo thanks so much
for coming on thanks for having me
Tanner listen a lot of animal rights
activists say that it is inhumane to
keep wild animals in captivity can you
speak to that you know quite frankly
whether I'm in captivity or not in
captivity I'm just happy to be living in
a maturity white country okay moving on
this isn't really a political show
tell me about Joe exotic I mean what's
this guy like you think he was framed I
mean do you think it deserves to get out
of prison I have full confidence in
Donald Trump that he'll freeze your
exotic after he arrests Barack Obama
what the hell are you talking about the
virus is faked in okay let's try to stay
on topic okay do you think Carole Baskin
murdered her husband are you Jewish get
him out of here cut his mic please trust
the plan that's the plan come on a storm
is coming off this is [ __ ] insane all
the Tigers are in the queue now it's the
third tiger we had they're all in the
queue it's insane